my ass is amazing I'm so into my um
thicker body I looked at photos of my
body when I was so skinny it
is cringy Courtney Kardashian is loving
her curves since finding love with hubby
Travis Barker I used to always say this
like when I'm super skinny just know I'm
not happy the pooch founder opens up on
Hulu's the Kardashians about how her
body has changed over the years
when I was super skinny it's like a time
that I was super anxious not about
eating not about staying at a certain
weight but like just in like toxic
relationships my weight I used to go so
much by weight oh my God it used to be
like 95 pounds and then I would be like
then like 105 became my new like normal
weight I'm 115. of course now court is
happy and in love with the Blink 182
drummer whom she married back in July
and she says that new number on the
scale is mainly because she underwent
IVF so she and Travis could try to have
a child eight months of IVF treatment
has definitely taken a toll on my body
mentally and physically and I think you
know it's taken a lot to get me to the
place of feeling really comfortable and
happy with
um the changes
everyone always comments like in every
photo like I'm pregnant and like
obviously we wish that but if it's in
God's plan you know then it is the
reality star has been open about their
fertility Journey from the get-go and
when ET sat down with court back in
April she admitted the process hasn't
been easy what has it been like to be on
the path to baby with Travis I mean it's
a beautiful thing that we'd love to have
happen
um but you know the journey is a bit
hard for any women who have been on it
and emotional mm-hmm
of course Court shares three children
with her ex Scott Disick 12 year old
mason 10 year old Penelope and
seven-year-old Reign while Travis has
two kids with his ex Shayna Moakler 18
year old Landon and 16 year old Alabama
my children are my first priority and
you know that's one thing that you know
Travis Knight you know do agree on you
know our children come first and their
happiness and as long as you know the
Kardashians are good to my kids you know
that's all that matters to me as a mom a
source previously told ET that the idea
of having a child is very important and
exciting to the couple and their family
is very supportive of the idea oh we all
love it this is her time to shine baby
in the meantime the lovebirds are just
enjoying married life we're just you
know living our best lives and Court
explains how Trav has helped her love
the skin she's in regardless of her size
I mean every day like Travis is like
you're perfect if I make one complaint
he's like oh you're perfect you're so
fine you've never been like better and
now I'm like I'm so into it having a
partner who's so supportive of me helped
me to really
embrace the changes
[Music]